you
this whole business of all these lenses
is ridiculous you know it's like you
have to capture your picture you have to
create it you have to see it you have to
seize it and you have to move in to get
it so those lenses are just an escape of
some sort or a shield I think that
people get into trouble when they
photograph something that they that is
not in their world it's like when they
say write what you know I can't tell you
how many reshoots I've done from you
know famous photographers who really
love just to shoot models and failed at
shooting a Patti LaBelle or someone like
that because Patti LaBelle didn't turn
them on so you have to shoot what you
care about for me if there's not a
component of intelligence or music or
culture or something that is fascinating
to me I really don't care about
photographing the person that's just
it's it's a it's about that
psychological exchange that's what is
interesting to me I think that people
have to just go with their gut and and
follow their passion if they're
photographers
I really have been lucky to have a lot
of mentors in the music industry Quincy
Jones almond or digan Jerry Wexler Bob
krasnow Bruce lundvall you know all
label heads and that error is again the
music industry error is gone but those
rules still apply because you know the
record business is kind of a metaphor
for life in a lot of ways just because
of all the components that had to come
together and make an artist and most of
these people except for almond you know
came came from the street and built
empires and you asked before about what
would I recommend to young photographers
make sure you have mentors you know to
teach you because you can't you can't
just intuit life by yourself especially
now
I think mentoring is essential in life
both being a mentor to someone and being
mentored and I think that when you are
mentored it inspires a generosity in you
to mentor others and that that I know is
what happened with me so for instance
the people that come through my studio
to work for me it's not good enough for
me to just give them a paycheck I want
to help them get to where they will you
know I don't care if it's you know an
intern or a full-time employee I want to
help them arrive at who they are or who
they they want to be in the world and
that's one of the questions I asked them
when I meet them you know who do they
want to be so I think that that's an
essential part of life and if you don't
get to do that and receive it you're
missing something